Olha essa tecnologia que acabou de
chegar ao Brasil e que pode mudar
completamente o jeito como operamos
câncer. Sério, quando eu vi isso, eu
fiquei impressionado. É uma caneta. Isso
mesmo, uma caneta chamada Mass Spec Pen,
que consegue identificar em tempo real
se um tecido é saudável ou cancerígeno
durante a cirurgia. Então, o cirurgião
encosta a ponta da caneta no tecido, ela
libera uma gotinha de água estére,
coleta moléculas da superfície, em até
90 segundos a inteligência artificial
analisa tudo e dá o resultado ali na
hora. Agora veja bem, porque isso é tão
importante. Durante uma cirurgia de
câncer, a gente sempre tem aquela
dúvida, será que eu tirei tudo? Será que
não tirei demais? Com essa caneta, essa
decisão fica muito mais precisa. Você
remove só o que precisa e preserva o
tecido saudável. Isso significa menos
chance de deixar células cancerígenas
para trás e ao mesmo tempo menos
mutilação do paciente. Pois é, o melhor
dos dois mundos. Agora a caneta entra em
fase de testes clínicos aqui no Brasil
com paciente de câncer de pulmão
antireoide. Se tudo der certo, a gente
pode estar vendo o futuro da cirurgia
oncológica acontecendo bem aqui.